nos discussions ne se trouve sur douche
bag chic car j'ai beaucoup de mal à dire
ça j'ai encore la joue une fille qui
veut avoir des grosses fesses des
énormes seins des jolis pieds avec des
escarpins et un visage d'une beauté
inégalée au games est parti dit nous
laissons aux verts de loin premièrement
de trouver un métier à temps cette fille
elle pas mieux que celle qu'on a vue sur
l'écran d'accueil qu elle puisse agir
rien par contre pour le vert ça non ça
non je suis désolé il ya quand même pas
déconner allez on va trouver un taf mon
gars c'est pas tout mais on va être bg
ok on prend le bus boutique art shopping
juste trouver un travail
bon bah beauty care mère des jumelles se
trouve à un travail la hausse et coface
est ce que n'a vraiment envie d'être
comme elle brise s'implante tout eu déjà
on va travailler se retrouvent un
travail
allez sur l'ordi le conte le co j'ai mis
20 $ dans un bus pour rien faire [ __ ]
de là c'est quoi ces l'épilation des
sourcils monde à l'endroit un travail on
peut être caissier ou alors serveuse
serveuse à clé pour boire c'est un bon
plan ça à mr x giuly entre pas et
caissières tessières on peut acheter
n'importe quoi bon une fois joué avec
les cercles sont très jolies voilà
d'ailleurs james tape tape vite au
mohawk est marché du coup aujourd'hui je
fais quoi rien jardin j'ai rien à faire
et ce que je peux avoir des amis allez
on va s'ajouter des amis mec voilà le
nom on apporte lundi sur twitter c'est
oh mon dieu c'est acté mais rui de la
vie je sais ce que ces gamines
mais ça finit toujours par s'en aller
alors on ne parlait alors on arrête
d'être négatif
voilà écouter on va juste dormir et on
va aller bosser de mains ok on est
debout c'est parti on va aller au [ __ ]
de supermarché faites péter puisque 96
dollars mon gars du coup on va faire
quoi on va
allez au beauty care avoir la meuf au
sein qui repose sur la table dans une
bâche en plastique make up of great
hockey à c'est bien ça ou aussi se
refaire les cheveux au beau et on va
aussi se refaire à chercher ça coûte
extrêmement cher ça ok liposuccion watts
en mai mais qu'on a on a des cornes
ajusta de maquillage dégueulasse qui
soit totalement ils ont mal fait le
contour des yeux allez on va au travail
il ya de l'argent c'est cool on va aller
faire du shopping à pau qui s'opposent à
acheter là un petit haut en bas on
attend ça j'ai jamais eu ça c'est quoi
c'est un semi dès que vous ayez vu ça
n'achetez pas ça franchement niveau je
suis savaria pas besoin qu est ce qu il
nous manquerait là une petite jupe aller
la baule du plus haut par deux cougar
boom s'appelle toujours ça on s'en fout
aux mondiaux à faire une fête ça coûte
20 $ on pourra toujours trahi saft soit
ou non ont fait de cette mère mondiaux à
faire une chimère et loire zéro faute
fresnes
j'ai déjà eu des bisous oui avec cette
vidéo qui dépasse 30 avr j'ai déchiré
c'est robidas alors à travailler on va
où
qu'est-ce qu'on peut se faire danny
gobeil tu sais quoi
oh mon dieu on se fait des uv mao
pourquoi c'est bien tu chez moi ici elle
peut travailler pour moi on veut
exploiter nos potes c'est horrible à
leon nord [ __ ] les gars notre vie
c'est dormir travailler dormir et j'en
peux plus chaud que j'en peux plus de
cette garde et on dort on se lève on va
vip et des packs de lait puis revenir
dormir là j'ai besoin j'ai besoin de mes
implants j'ai besoin de chercher besoin
de deux têtes d'être très très mal j'ai
besoin d'avoir un coût énorme je sature
aujourd'hui et un nouveau jour hilton
bon bulletin météo mais casser ce cap
god work je m'en bats les couilles j'ai
hérité de 1000 $ mon gars qu'est ce
qu'on va faire on va aller au centre de
beauté où va faire quoi
les implants c'est très bien oui je veux
qu'il soit gros je veux qu'ils soient
énormes encore oui oh oui des lèvres
énorme je veux quand je fasse la bise à
quelqu'un il est carrément un suçon
après oui là je suis trop gros je suis
trop gros je veux maigrir oui maigrir ah
oui les cheveux c'est quoi cette coupe
bah ouais moi je veux le blond platine
voilà enfin la terrine sdf qui a hérité
et qui a fait n'importe quand année on
veut être plus bronzé qu'un black voile
attentats tatatata tankessé êtes tenus
lors que vous faites du shopping mais
c'est un mec c'est n'importe quoi
ces vêtements x2 qu'est ce qu'on a en
jupe là bas ça tiens pourquoi cacher tes
fesses quand tu veux que les gens les
regardent c'est vrai c'est vrai que
dis-je mais que dis-je saumon norman se
balader comme ça et là où c'est son
affaire là on va rentrer à la maison et
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va faire la
fête
beach au caire ce câble le soleil se
lève avec qui on a fait l'amour cette
nuit papa va changer de métier un moment
on va devenir une superstar alors
fourchette de 150 mec pardon quoi tout
ça faut coucher avec 200 mecs un salaire
mensuel satirique c'est très important
les mecs c'est pareil on suit devient
une star farouk chèques des gens du coup
on accrochait qu'une seule personne du
qu'on peut faire quoi
ben voilà enfin on va devoir faire des
fêtes de plus en plus de fait à ma tâche
de fond n'a pas tout c'est pour ça mon
dieu on n'a pas acheté les terres des
louboutin ah oui là je suis bien
aulas je suis bien c'est bien au nom je
vais tourner jogging adidas [ __ ] c'est
bon c'est bon on a tous on a 90 % de
tout matériel comme entre pourquoi j'ai
tout acheté aux mondiaux scarpa qui sont
sortis au moment où j'ai sorti la
boutique j'avais pas vu au
aulas c'est bon on a tout faux va
pouvoir se changer mettre la tenue la
plus biatch possible pour attirer le
plus d'hommes possible tout droit dans
nos fesses ce soir voilà ça ça ça
devrait être bien pu s'y verront que
c'est une fille bien et que je couche
pas le premier soir comme ça ce parfait
allez on va faire la fête quoi faire la
fête nous il faut qu'on baise on veut
devenir une star c'est le moment de
faire la meilleure fait de cette ville
ok c'est la fin de cette soirée avec
combien d'hommes avant nous coucher cinq
mois tout à fait pas seulement aux
belles dames en 2014 omme chaque mois
c'est incroyable qui paraît une fille
comme ça pour son physique ça se voit
que c'est une meuf bien et ça se voit
que c'est pas genre de meuf à coucher le
premier soir
8 on a fait l'amour avec huit hommes au
total en seulement quatre nuits et la
première nuit c'était notre première
fois deux cent soixante ans a vu mon
gars là on commence à faire des fêtes
on entend parler de loin on se fait
cette taxe aux mondiaux toujours plus de
fiches et moi c'est incroyable
tiens j'ai mal aux doigts tellement je
dois accepter de nombreuses demandes
c'est incroyable à sites sûrs d'être une
[ __ ] c'est l'heure de faire une fête
combien d'hommes combien d'arbres
combien d'hommes 12 allez-y péter moi tu
veux devenir mannequin comme ce sera
jamais je passe mes journées à accepter
des deux mains mais c'est pour devenir
une star alors ça vaut le coup déminer
dollars dépensés dans des fêtes beaucoup
d'hommes dans son lit encore plus de
gens qui meurent en rien dans le salon
c'est maintenant devenu une star et on a
mal au cul tellement voilà je vais pas
vous mentir on est une star
allez on va travailler on a gagné 800 au
bosc une heure en touche mille dollars
[ __ ] ça va être une star ben voilà bah
du coup maintenant on veut ma vie c'est
de la merde
et voilà home et puis c'est déjà la fin
de cette eau sur douchebag chick n'était
pas là mais ça vous a plu tout ça pour
dire que les filles peu importe votre
physique peu importe vos complexes ou
quoi aimer vous comme vous êtes
cherchait pas à avoir des seins plus
gros cherchait pas à avoir un énorme
coup j'achète pas avoir tellement de
maquillage sur la gueule qu'on voit même
plus un millimètre carré de votre vraie
peau vous êtes très jolie comme vous
êtes vous avez pas besoin de toute cette
merde ça marche pas mal mais franchement
tout ça c'est des futilités et les
covers ans vous ne vous laissez pas
influencer parce que sur les affiches y
tourner mais extrêmement maigre convois
qui ont des seins comme ça inclut comme
ça ce sont des aliens ça n'existe pas
d'accord allez c'est la conclusion de
cette vidéo c'est beau c'est beau petite
musique romantique
ouais